we're taking the audience to a place
that none of these IMAX films or any
other film has taken audience members to
West Papua is the most diverse
underwater habitat anywhere on earth
it's an underwater paradise that's
unlike any other it's such a special
place and I think what's amazing too is
that the people have built a way of life
to protect that natural environment
they've found ways to protect their own
reefs
it's a pristine underwater environment
and that's why we wanted to make an IMAX
film there
we were lucky to find this great
character a young Island boy named Joey
who kind of represents his culture
dedication and keeping the reefs healthy
we follow him on a journey aboard the
cala bia which is a boat that travels
among the islands teaching kids about
the importance of their reach we knew
that we could use him with the Cala BIA
to really form the basis of our new IMAX
film journey to the South Pacific his
energy and infectious smile just brings
the film to life we see West Papua
through his eyes and learn about this
amazing place with him one of the
highlights of the film was our trip to
warm on the last remaining habitat of
the Pacific leatherback turtle and we
had another thrill when we were filming
the whale sharks these are the two
largest sea creatures of their kind and
to use IMAX cameras they use the largest
film format in the world and show them
on the world largest screens audiences
are just going to be blown away so it's
our job to try to capture all of that in
a way that allows the audience member to
feel like he is sharing that experience
with us and IMAX is the only format that
can do that the quality of the IMAX 1570
format is the highest quality that there
is why not
and it was so wonderful to come into
these villages where life is just joyful
the shoot we did over in West Papua will
be one of our premiere films the
experience was kind of magical in a way
what we captured there in terms of the
story of these villagers through the
eyes of Joey I think there's a great
deal that audiences can learn and enjoy
that's why I love making these movies
not only are we opening the eyes of the
audience but we're opening our own eyes
I don't really think bringing this
remarkable location to people on the
IMAX screen it's gonna be an experience
unlike any other
you